Bill Cosby's accusers are among those
applauding the Pennsylvania judge's
decision to send him to prison as we
reported the Akron comedian was
sentenced yesterday to 3 to 10 years
behind bars for drugging and sexually
assaulting Andrea constant in 2004 he is
the first major celebrity sent to prison
in the me2 era and all more than 60
women have accused Cosby of sexual
misconduct we're joined now by one of
those accusers her name is Victoria
Valentino and she joins us at the table
Victoria it's very good to see you this
morning thank you for having me I have
to start with this server so many people
who were waking up who still can't
believe that America's dad is in prison
I know that you were in the courtroom
yesterday you sit here as an accuser and
to that you say what he wasn't America's
dad to me mm-hmm when I met him it was
1969 and he was starring in I spy this
was before he did the Huxtable show you
know The Cosby Show so after that
experience I left Los Angeles and I went
on a healing Odyssey basically for the
last at about 12 years I walked away
from my career you were how old if I was
26 96 and it was right after my
six-year-old son had drowned in a
swimming pool which he knew about and he
used my grief to get to my roommate who
he had the hots for you feel he took
advantage of that situate in that
courtroom obviously this is something
that has altered your life this happened
decades ago justice has finally been
served but what was it like in the
courtroom to see that he wasn't
remorseful he was very defensive and he
never apologized how important is it she
or is it at this point to have that
apology from him well I don't think
it'll matter because first of all I
believe he's sociopathic he has no
conscience therefore even if he
apologized it wouldn't it wouldn't
matter it would just be an act it would
be something to engender sympathy from
the public did you feel something
watching him in court yesterday oh
absolutely we were all shaking we were
shaking all of us sister survivors were
sitting in the back row holding hands
and just waiting for the moment waiting
for the moment waiting for the moment
and then of course there were all these
appeals and discussions and arguments
and so finally when we did hear the
sentencing it was almost anticlimactic
but you were telling me at dinner you
had a moment last night when you had to
reflect on it when you saw him yeah what
was that well when he was brought out in
handcuffs his jacket was off and his
baggy pants were being held up by
suspenders and I had this moment of
feeling sorry for him because he seemed
suddenly so frail and that arrogant
pompous rather terrifying presence
mm-hmm
was no longer there but then I saw a
smirk on his face he still had that
jokey smirk but in the courtroom he was
still delusional II thinking that he was
going to get out on bail because when
they registered him as a violent sexual
predator and told him that he had to
register in any city that he went to he
asked them well do I have to register if
I'm just going to another city for for
the evening and staying overnight and
then going back home and that was when
we realized he really thought up until
the last that he was going to be out on
bail and go home well they are planning
on appealing though yelling are you
concerned at all that there's even a 1%
chance that he could be acquitted
I am not concerned because the arguments
are that it's because he's so old that
he couldn't possibly hurt another woman
and if he were in his home with an ankle
bracelet but let's face it that's where
he raped Andrea constant Victoria your
capacity to feel sorry for him just in
that moment did that represent for you
that something had changed for you are
you now in a new place now that this has
come down this word well particularly
this morning I think I was running on
adrenaline last night
and we were just talking about it and
you know tying everything up and feeling
vindicated and validated and this
morning I'm feeling it really emotional
and I and I'm trying to process it you
know I'm trying to understand why I'm
feeling so emotional and of course
walking into the green room and all the
newspapers with this picture of Anya you
know and and the booking shots and
everything and then I just have to keep
reminding myself how arrogant and how
pompous and how entitled he was
throughout all three trials which I've
been to you know I I've been through the
whole on your own time what message does
it send to survivors excuse me what
message does his conviction send to
survivors
well it says that no matter how wealthy
no matter how powerful no matter how
famous you are not above the law thank
you very much for Toria for my pleasure
sharing that all with us thank you thank
you